Most of the times, having data
in our database is a good idea.
But sometimes, we make a few bad ideas
that we may want to delete, later.
Auntie Anne's Diner just realized, that
their spinach ice cream wasn't a hit,
and wants to remove it from their menu.
Deleting an item is a three step
process similar to updating.
First, we want to execute the query
to find the spinach ice cream, and
store it in a variable.
Then we want to call session
delete on that item.
And finally, we'll commit the session.
Let's go back to the Python shell,
and walk through this together.
Let's assume, Auntie Anne's was the only
restaurant with spinach ice cream, and
use the .dot one function,
to grab this entry in the database.
To double check,
I will print out the name of the
restaurant, this menu item belongs to.
And see that it is indeed,
Auntie Ann's creation.
We will call session.delete
to stage this item for
removal from the database, and then call
session.commit to persist this change.
If we search for spinach now,
the sqlalchemy gives us, a no row was
found error, letting us know that this
data is no longer in our database.